i'm surprised one thing i'm surprised
that's not on here yeah is uh
trainspotting
because you've talked about that a bunch
[ __ ] you know what i completely forgot
about that
actually yeah can we can we get rid of
gold member and put train sporting no no
no no
please please do me a song no he did it
with the [ __ ] gaming three by three i
could do with the movie game okay
moon or whoever's editing get rid of
gold this is a [ __ ] movie anyway
gold member put train spotting on it
trains funny [ __ ] people
someone criticized me because they said
when someone they asked me what my
favorite video game or whatever was
i said different from what i put on my
three by three we make off three by
threes in like 10 minutes this is not
like the
end all of our actually exactly exactly
which try to make it interesting
yeah yeah they're fine i'm thinking oh
i've really enjoyed this is the end
by a seth rogen film oh what yeah and uh
what is uh 50 50 was pretty good
oh 50 50 was great i haven't seen any of
these
the ones where like the joke isn't just
him being a stoner
right right and that's why is that even
possible yeah
yeah yeah yeah all right okay yeah he
does because i think i think with seth
rogen like
i watched one film with seth rogen in it
and i was like was it pineapple express
it might have been that's and i was like
and i was like i
a hundred percent understand this actor
in this character he's probably like
that in every other movie
yeah i don't know yeah it's just one of
those oh my god [ __ ] can i talk about
transporting okay okay sorry sorry sorry
so good okay have you guys seen it i
have not
you haven't seen it okay so train
spotting is this like oh god how do you
how the [ __ ] do you explain
train sporting i know that it's not
about spotting trains it is not about
spotting
so the term train spotting comes from
heroin addicts where they
try to uh inject the heroin into their
veins
so they have to spot the veins and that
is referred to as train spotting
yes yeah so basically it's a it's a drug
film uh
set in scotland uh played uh mainly by
europe mcgregor
yeah who is in his natural habitat he's
in his natural uh accent so you know
it's going to be good uh very very young
you and mcgregor yeah i think this is
before star wars
i think i think the one thing i remember
from train spotting apart from the baby
scene yeah
uh was just toilet scene yeah just you
mcgregor
emerges from a toilet yeah i've heard
about this yeah i've heard
of the scenes in trains yeah it's a very
famous scene is where your mcgregor
needs to go
you know do a hit and he's at a pub and
he goes into the closest
no no that's right no he uh he gets the
runs i think from something yeah and he
runs into a pub and goes into the
probably the most disgusting looking
toilet imagine oh yeah
yeah like it's it's like it's actually
foul and he
drops his drugs into the toilet oh and
because he's a desperate junkie
and he took a shot beforehand he starts
hallucinating as he
reaches into the toilet and just goes
into the toilet and starts swimming into
the inside the toilet
emerges out of the toilet with the drugs
oh my god it's a very
very bizarre movie but i uh i
showed trainspotting to aki right and
she was she stopped it after five
minutes and she's like can we put
subtitles on because i can't understand
what the [ __ ] they're saying
to be fair it's a very heavy scottish
accent
like there are some scenes where even
i'm like oh i didn't quite catch what he
just [ __ ] said there so like
americans that's what i'm saying
probably best to put subtitles being
from the uk is like your english level
is op
yeah i understand any any form of
english the only reason why
the only reason why i understand train
spotting is because i like watched it
like over 10 times
i just remember what they say but uh
yeah i don't know it's just like it's
very
brutal film but also it's like again
like the music choices
like yeah with me with movies if it's
got a great music choice i'm all for it
yeah same with my anime right if the ost
is good
it's a great movie i'd say if there's
like two like drug
like films kind of like what how do i
how do i describe this
is that a category yeah
because like i don't really know how to
describe trainspotting it's just a movie
about a bunch of characters
and that's sold on it to be fair and
like how their lives revolve around
drugs and like
trainspotting is one of them and the
other one is requiem for a dream yeah
which is not a film
i think like people should watch to
enjoy
but i think people should just watch it
at least once yes
like realize wow i just just never want
to try heroin
yeah i just that's that's just a bad
thing well i mean train sporting was
definitely one where i was like oh
never touching that [ __ ] yeah in my life
[ __ ] that [ __ ] that
yeah you know i was 50 50 but uh
if you ever have a friend who's like
maybe i might try heroin just show them
train spawn they'll probably be like
nope never drink
him for a dream or record for a dream i
think i just got full on [ __ ]
depression for a week after watching
that film i mean train sporting is
definitely another film
that is not watched for entertainment
yeah yeah probably more entertaining
than recording for a dream
i would like to say like train spotting
isn't a happy movie but it's like less
bleak than wrecking for a dream
there's a lot there's a lot of great
scenes and it's like i don't know just
again the acting's really good and it's
just very
it's a very raw film yeah requiem for a
dream just sounds like something you'd
give an oscar to based on the title
to be fair there's some great [ __ ]
scenes
like [ __ ] that's awesome yeah the thing
i can say about rec room for a dream is
that it's just
it's a [ __ ] powerful movie and it's
like it's makes you feel emotions that
it's not pleasant feeling
yeah but it's [ __ ] powerful [ __ ] man
speaking of powerful
should we uh get onto my list go on